bonjour je m'appelle Jean-Luc noirband
je suis secrétaire de l'association
l'éclair rando
[Musique]
la caractéristique de notre club c'est
de
d'organiser des randonnées tout au long
de la semaine et selon des rythmes et
des endroits différents ce qui est
important pour nous c'est trois
objectifs
la découverte sportive donc le fait de
faire un exercice physique le la
découverte de des différents sites de
notre région sachant que le département
des Yvelines est plein de à la fois de
forêt de monuments de chemin et donc des
très très intéressantes en termes de de
découverte et puis enfin et très
important le lien social que l'on
cherche à renforcer développer puisque
c'est vraiment l'occasion en marchant de
découvrir les personnes avec qui on
marche et qui sont des personnes qui
habitent autour de nous
[Musique]
en pleine ville au Vésinet qu'on appelle
le circuit des petites rivières qui est
vraiment une un petit circuit plat de 7
km qui va se promener dans des petits
chemins et qui nous permet de découvrir
les très belles demeures de cette ville
assez costume les Yvelines
un endroit qui est l'autre un peu le
terrain de chasse favori c'est la forêt
de Rambouillet dans la forêt de
Rambouillet j'aime beaucoup un circuit
autour des de l'abbaye des hauts Cernay
qui est assez vallonné et avec au milieu
de ça un beau monument qui est le qui
est l'abbaye de vos cerné
[Musique]
un autre type de circuit qui va être un
circuit plus à travers champ et
découvert des villages qu'on appelle le
circuit des trois lavoirs qui va de Ben
en passant par d'avrons et
crêpière également voilà qui fait une
vingtaine de kilomètres
[Musique]